we're on problem 190 190 if the
operations star with the circle around
it
star with the circle is defined for all
a and B by the equation a star with a
circle around it B is equal to a squared
times B over 3
then what does - I'm just gonna say star
with a circle around it 3 star with a
circle around it minus 1 equal so 3 star
minus 1 that's equal to let's see let's
do this in magenta 3 star minus 1 that's
equal to 3 squared times minus 1 which
is so that's just minus 3 squared or
minus 9 right 3 squared 9 times minus 1
is minus 9 divided by 3 which is equal
to minus 3 so this reduces to 2 star
minus 3 which is equal to 2 squared
which is 4 times minus 3 all of that
over 3 minus 3 divided by 3 that's just
minus 1 so we have minus 1 times 4 is
equal to minus 4 and that's choice C
problem 192 190 191 I want to skip
problems the inside dimensions of a
rectangular wooden box are 6 by 8 by 10
so 6 by 8 and then 10 hi by 10 a
cylindrical canisters to be placed
inside the box so it stands upright when
the closed box rests on one of its six
faces okay a cylindrical canisters to be
placed inside the box that stands
upright when the box with a closed box
rests on one of its six faces of all
such canisters that could be used what
is the radius in inches of the one that
has maximum volume
okay so we want to so they're gonna put
one canister in this box you're gonna
put one canister in this box and how do
you maximize its volume right so let's
think about it this way let's think
about it let's think about what a what a
volume of a cylinder is alright if this
is my cylinder its volume is the area of
the side times the height right and the
area of the side is equal to if this is
the radius it would be PI R squared
right it would be PI R squared times
times the height right height times PI R
squared
now what's what's are going to be equal
to write R has to go all the way around
so R is going to be equal to 1/2 well
and obviously equals 1/2 the diameter of
this circle but if we if we put it let's
think if we if we look at the base
that's six and eight if we use that as
the base and that the 10 comes out of
the page the radius can only be what the
radius can only be three because the
diameter of the circle can only be six
right we can't we don't get to use the 8
so this is the case if we use the six of
the eight side if we use and so will
kind of be I guess the best way to think
about is we'll be wasting this space
over here right the other possibility is
you use if we had the 8 in the 10 side 8
in the 10 side if this was our base if
this was our base then we could have a
radius of 4 right then we could have a
radius of 4 let me think about it yeah
radius would be a 4 because we would
have the height 8 we'd have a radius of
4 now when we look at this equation if
we had to maximize either the this is
going to be the volume of the cylinder
if we had to maximize either the height
or the radius because those are the two
things that we can deal with which one
at least to you seems more important
multiple to me the radius seems more
because I'm squaring it right so let's
see how if we if we so these in my mind
are the two contenders the worst
contender is where we use the six and
the ten side is the base right because
then we use a lot of space but we could
figure that one out too because then we
waste a lot of spaces we have a height
of eight and the radius is still so
first of all this one is clearly better
than this one and why is that they have
the same area of their base right
because the radius is six
I'm sorry the radius is three the
diameter is six but in here the height
gets to be ten and here the height is
only guess gets to be eight so this one
is a non option so really we have to
compare these two and and I've drawn
their bases right so if you think about
this one we have an area of the base of
65 well the radius is 4 so 16 pi times
the height of 6 times 6 that's the
volume of this cylinder here we have a
radius another radius ism we have a
radius of 3 right half of the six
diameter so the area is 9 pi and we're
going to multiply that times the height
which is 10 so here we have 90 pi and
here we have 6 times 16 which is 96 pi
so this is the best the best of our
cases and that was the correct intuition
we're maximizing the radius and when you
maximize the radius we get a radius of 4
so let's but what did they ask us is a
question again what is the radius in
inches of the one that has the maximum
volume and so that radius is 4 where one
side is 8 and one side is 10 and that's
choice B choice B next question 192
square root okay they have all sorts of
interesting things they essentially want
us to simplify the square root of 2 plus
1 times the square root of 2 minus 1
times the square root of 3 plus 1 times
the square root of 3 minus 1 so this
seems to be just an application of I'm
sure you've learned this in algebra that
a plus B
times a minus B is equal to a squared
minus B squared now you don't have to
memorize this you could actually
multiply it all out and you'll get this
but it's a good thing to know just if
you want to do things quickly so square
root of two plus one times square root
of two minus one is equal to square root
of two squared minus one squared right
and we're going to multiply that times
using the same principle square root of
three squared minus one squared square
root of two squared that's two minus one
times three minus one that's equal to
one times two which is equal to two and
that is choice a problem 193 193 in a
certain calculus class the ratio of the
number of math majors to the number of
students who are not math majors is two
to five some math - not math is equal to
two to five if two more math majors were
to enter the class the ratio would be
one to two so if I have two more math
majors then the ratio of them to the
non-math majors is equal to one to two
how many students are in the class so
they want to know what M plus M they
want to know what M plus nm non-math
majors is let's see let's see if we can
solve for anything we actually have two
linear equations in two unknowns you
might not see it yet but if we cross
multiply we get 5m
I'll just call these end non-math majors
I don't want to keep saying nm 5 m is
equal to 2 N and here you get 2 times M
plus 2 is 2 M plus 4 is equal to n is
equal to n we could substitute that
right if n is equal to that then that
means that 5 M is equal to 2 times n n
is equal to 2 M plus 4 2 M plus 4 so you
get 5 M is equal to 4 M plus 8 subtract
4 M from both
you get M is equal to 8 if M is equal to
8 we could say 5 M is equal to 2 n so 5
times 8 is 40 is equal to 2 N and so n
is equal to 20 and that's C are they
asking for the if two more students were
to enter the class okay so they want to
know how many in the class right now so
they want to know M plus N well that's
equal to 8 plus 20 which is equal to 28
students and that is choice D next
question I think I have time to fit this
one in I'll continue to the next video
if I don't 194
what is the unit's digit of 13 to the
fourth times 17 squared times 29 to the
third so here you just have to realize
that the unit's digit in any of these
numbers are just the unit's digit of
each of these numbers times each other
and then you take the unit's digit of
that so we really just have to worry
about the unit's digit the answer to
this question would be the exact same
thing as if I said the unit's digit of
three to the fourth right we just have
to worry about the unit's digits three
to the fourth times seven squared times
nine to the third it would be the exact
same thing if we were just 4 so 3 to the
fourth what's the unit's digit 3 to the
1 is equal to 3 3 squared is equal to 9
3 to the third is 27 but the unit's
digit is 7 and then 3 to the fourth is
81 and the unit's digit is 1 and and
just so you can see this principle that
I just talked about and we could prove
it if I had more time is that look I
could just multiply 3 times 7 and the
unit's digit is just 1 or I could just
multiply 3 times 9 and the and the used
digit is 7 we could just ignore
everything else
so here the unit's digit is 1 7 squared
what's the unit's digit well 7 squared
the unit's digit is well 7 squared is 49
the unit's digit is 9 and then 9 to the
third what's the unit's digit 9 to the 1
is 9 9 2 squared the unit's digit is 1
right it's 81
and then nine to the third we'd have to
worry about anything else when you
multiply 81 times 9 the unit's digit is
going to be nine times that one and 81
so that equals nine so it's 1 times 9
times 9 and then 9 times 9 is 81 and we
want the unit's digit which is 1 so the
answer is e and I'll let you think about
that a little bit maybe you want to play
around and see why we only have to worry
about the unit's digit why I was able to
make this statement right here to avoid
doing a lot of harder math anyway see
you in the next video